uh one of the things that was suggested
during the first presidential debate
by donald trump was that trump suggested
his supporters
go to the polls and observe
what's going on hang out at polling
places see if things look okay
now as i mentioned if you there are poll
workers
and there are poll volunteers you can't
just
show up and volunteer on the day of you
have to actually
sign up to do that if you just show up
and you're quote observing and you're
you're essentially loitering
in some states that's against the law
and it's voter intimidation
and nevada's attorney general is not
taking this lightly and has said if you
do what trump is suggesting
we will arrest you and we will prosecute
you because it is in nevada illegal
let's start with a reminder about what
donald trump said
about this tuesday night at the debate
but it is so i
first for you sir finally for the for
the vice president i hope neither of you
will interrupt the other
will you urge your supporters to stay
calm
during this extended period not to
engage in any
civil unrest and will you pledge tonight
that you will not declare
victory until the election has been
independently certified
president trump thank you very much my
supporters to go into the polls
and watch very carefully because that's
what has to happen
i am urging them to do it as you know
today there was a big problem in
philadelphia they went in to watch they
were
called poll watchers a very safe very
nice thing they were thrown out they
weren't allowed to watch
you know why because bad things happen
in philadelphia bad things
so the reason trump's poll watchers were
thrown
out is that they weren't actually poll
watchers there's a process
if you want to be a volunteer you have
to actually
sign up typically it's run at the county
level but you'd have to see how it is in
your your city state or municipality
you don't just show up or show up armed
as someone uh who is there to observe
the way donald trump is suggesting it's
not going to do
it's voter intimidation to hang out all
day at polls without being an actual
volunteer
who signed up and is on a list of
someone who's going to be there to do
that and trump is encouraging that
trump is encouraging voter intimidation
and it shouldn't surprise us trump
encouraged
try to vote twice that's a felony in
some places including north carolina
trump has encouraged all sorts of
behavior that is either
immoral or illegal in some cases and
nevada's attorney general says
we will prosecute people who do this if
you do this we will prosecute prosecute
you
if you follow donald trump's advice and
you go to polling places and you
monitor votes being cast or counted uh
it is voter intimidation aaron ford
tweeted quote
trump also told his supporters
to go into the polls and watch very
carefully
but he wasn't talking about poll
watching he was talking about voter
intimidation
for your information voter intimidation
is illegal in nevada
believe me when i say it you do it and
you will be prosecuted
now to follow up on trump's claim
that some injustice has transpired
because his fans who showed up in philly
weren't allowed in
we looked into it legitimate poll
officers
and volunteers in philadelphia have been
able to do their jobs
but you have to actually be there in an
official capacity
random people who show up and say i'm
gonna watch
aren't actually part of anything they
can't hang out intimidating people
that's not i was gonna say it's not how
our democracy works
it's not how our democracy is supposed
to work
now for you what to do if you see funny
business
when you go to vote three things to keep
in mind number one
you can report voter intimidation to the
aclu
by calling 866 hour vote put it in your
phone
number two you can report voter
intimidation
or electioneering or whatever to the
local county elections board
again most elections are run at the
county level that's why we get results
county by county often on election night
google the phone number
for your county elections board put it
in your phone before you go
you can safe if you can safely and
legally get video of what's going on
send it to me i will do everything i can
to send it to my media contacts and to
publicize it on this program
this applies to early voting the
supplies on election day we will be
standing by on election day
uh to hear from you if funny business is
going on it's
also important for people to know what
is and is not permitted in their
jurisdiction
so there's a brief summary of poll
watcher laws
available uh we're linking to a website
that has that summary
in the description to this youtube clip
so you've got it or you can just google
uh poll watcher laws massachusetts poll
watcher laws louisiana or whatever state
you live in so like as an example in new
york
each party can have three poll watchers
present
and the poll watchers can challenge your
right to vote when you appear at the
polling place
but it would not override any
anti-discrimination laws if they're
challenging every black voter
or disproportionately black voters that
wouldn't be okay
you know enforcing it in the heat of
election day is another question
it also never permits harassment
intimidation coercion electioneering
trying to either
prevent someone from voting or
influencing vote so that's new york
understand the laws in your state and
yeah
it's tragic that this is how we have to
prepare
to go and vote uh my plan for now
um is i i do have an absentee ballot
coming
and if it gets to me reasonably soon i
don't know when massachusetts is sending
them out i
i would fill it out and drop it off
personally
otherwise i might avail myself of the
early voting that takes place
in massachusetts that's my thought let
me know
your plan i'm on twitter at dpakman and
remember
that if you prefer a long-form audio
podcast
each day rather than short youtube clips
or facebook video clips
you can find our audio podcast just
about on any podcast platform itunes
stitcher spotify so on and so forth uh
uh find us there
let me know your voting plan on twitter
at dpakman
and we will be right back if you've been
watching the show you've probably heard
me talk about how much i love
my helix mattress well i was really
excited to hear that helix has launched
a new company called
all form which makes premium
customizable sofas and chairs
with the same level of quality and
comfort
that i expect from these guys and all
form is one of our sponsors today
they're giving you twenty percent off at
allforum.com
pacman they actually sent me a couch
which i put
in my living room at home it's now my
favorite piece of furniture
in the house it took me just minutes to
set it up
it's solidly built it's huge it's roomy
it has a modern minimalist design which
i love but it's also
very comfortable fabric is soft clearly
very high quality
it has become the focal point of my
living room
their prices are very reasonable and
when you get a new sofa or
chair you get 100 days to decide if you
want to keep it and the best
part is everything comes with a lifetime
warranty
stop buying poorly made furniture go to
customize
your own all form sofa or chair right
now
and get 20 percent off your entire order
when you get there
by going to all form dot com slash
pacman
i've also put the link right underneath
this video